the red sox wearing the nike mlb
city connect series uniforms today
they'll also wear those tomorrow
the colors honoring the boston marathon
nick pavetta off to a two-and-oh start
yeah pavetta hasn't done much wrong
since he came over from philly last year
won four games two last year and two
this year coming off his sixth inning
win against baltimore last time out
waved down and missed he struck him out
run away and that's going to be ball
four so he's walked back to back men
two on for jose abreu
abreu fair down the third base line
four hitting jose abreu's got an rbi
eaton scores
and that's all they'll get it's an rbi
double here in the first inning
for the sox new cleanup hitter well this
worked out rather well with jose in the
four spot there's a slider that doesn't
slide
you can pretty much see the rotation you
can also see the fact that it stays on
the outer third without a whole lot of
break
jose takes it down the line past the
diving devers
mercedes on the ground that will get a
run home it's an rbi ground ball and
it's a two nothing white sox lead with
abreu going to third
dylan both of his starts four and two
thirds innings four hits he threw it
pretty well last time out
wants to keep the pitch count to a
minimum one and two
martinez to abreu gets one there tim
back to first that's brilliant that was
ballet from the white sox infield to
turn two
against the red sox devers always a
threat
he already has five home runs this year
that's a high fly ball to right eaton is
back on it eaton's at the track and adam
eaton reels it in
against the wall nice play by adam for
out number one that ball would have been
gone had there not been number 12 at the
wall
well this right field was designed to
give the outfielder a chance to go up
and over the wall and make a play i like
a lower fence maybe not this low but i
like a
lower fence because of this he goes back
good concentration he knows he's going
to feel the contact
he secures the baseball takes the
contact
really nice slider strike three locked
up gonzales
i don't think the red sox planned on
dylan sees throwing a lot of straight
changes
and a lot of sliders he is a power
pitcher
but he's using his whole repertoire here
early in this one
kk hernandez about to lead things off
the 2-1 to kiki
hammered off the third baseman monkatta
that's fair down the line
keeps on rolling he's heading into
second base and he is two for two today
now that's what you need a little bit of
that action
off the mid all the way to the backstop
hernandez will trot into third
verdugo will climb in next all for one
with a strikeout
and a fly ball into right eating right
there
tagging up [ __ ] hernandez he is in the
score and the red sox are on the
scoreboard
on the rbi by verdugo his 12th it's a
2-1 game martinez and bogart's aboard
and there's a shot out to right he will
make the catch
tagging up martinez here comes jd throw
goes into first base and the red sox
have tied it up
rafael devers hits another one on the
button that is caught by
eaton and ties the game yeah sacrifice
fly
sacrifice line drive to right field
eaton
he doesn't get it airborne he hits a
missile like a line drive right at eaton
that's two bullets that he's hit in the
game today
and he hasn't been on base yet dylan
cease will work the fourth inning for
the white sox
strike three on a fastball quickly
cordero
set aside now he'll walk it the other
way
three pitches no contact that's a good
moving fastball it's just off the plate
perfect 0-2 pitch
3-2 that one got him flashing over the
outside corner
look he didn't like the call by gabe
morales but he's got to get pitches for
his pitcher so he doesn't say too much
that actually had the corner that was a
great pitcher's pitch
flower can't believe it
that was a really good one a biting
slider down and away
and dylan c strikes out the side in the
fourth
so plawecki next he's flying out and
struck out
socked into center field pretty well hit
robert beckett's over his head
so plawecki will trot into second base
with a two-out
double yeah robert looked like he had a
beat on that ball
yeah that ball was hit harder than they
thought it was hit
on contact hanging breaking ball yeah
spin it right there
right over the middle of the plate
that's good throwing a slider instead of
a change up
two bases for the red sox catcher his
first hit today
two strike pitch now for marshall
base hit up the middle flecky trying to
score
here's the throw he's in and the red sox
lead it
3-2 boston king case had quite a day
that's his third hit yes he has got
burnt on two sliders powecky and then
hernandez up the middle they try to
throw him out at home he's going to
score easy robert's throw over throws
the cutoff band and [ __ ] takes second
base
sucks now we'll have tim anderson at the
plate
this one into center a base hit i don't
think they're going to stay with andres
too long
you don't think so i was surprised he
came out for yeah for the seventh i
think
i thought the socks were going to score
if kim gets on we'll have to see if that
plays itself out
that is a slider and this is a good
pitch jim just goes down and gets it
takes it into center field that's his
first hit of the day
tim runs flowecki's throw is high and it
ricochets into short center field
tim peels away and he's going to get to
third
[Applause]
moncada skyward to left center tim's
going to come home
[Applause]
and here comes the tying run he is saved
no call timber he's got to touch the
plate yes there it is good call
right and this throw makes it very close
hernandez usually a shortstop he's got a
very good arm the throw is pretty good
he's got the plate i think it looked
like he had the plate on the first swipe
but
morales did not call it the ball gets
away and then he's just looking at him
tim is looking at him
there is no safe sign cody hoyer into
the game boy he's been
absolutely brilliant six and two thirds
innings eight strikeouts
one walk yes he does
one down that was a dandy of a slider
and he just overmatched a very good
hitter in jd martinez
he sets him up for a slider away it's
down and out of the strike zone
did he go says and there is that high
fastball up and in
set up with low sliders you change the
eye angle and then you heat them
upstairs and you get one of these
that bat path went a long way across the
front of the plate
there it is strike three cody hoyer
strikes out the side
man for the socks it'll be marwin
gonzalez against hoyer
high fly ball that one driven deep to
right on the run eaton looking up
well what a time to hit your first red
sox home run
marwin gonzalez and the bottom of the
eighth has put the red sox in the lead
he was due he was due i'll tell you what
after all these change-ups i think he
gets a high fast point he's got a high
fast forward he absolutely turned on it
look at this
i mean that that a lot of time is a
swinging miss
a ball up around the letters like that
at that velocity
and he's able to get it and crush it
over the bullpen
i mean what a time to turn it on and he
leaves the yard
and low for ball for he walked in the
run
scores and the red sox are up 5-3
jd martinez picks up the rbi
hernandez at third verdugo at second
martinez at first
two huge runs here in the eighth for the
sox and a one-two pitch
i fly right field along the line here
comes eden coming coming coming that's a
fair ball
that jumps into the stands but it's
going to be a double
and the red sox indeed busted open
that's the fourth hit today for zander
just tucked it inside the line and the
socks lead it
seven to three what a beautiful thing oh
there's been a couple of dandy's down
there right field line today
and now the baseball will go to matt
barnes and you see his toes six games
he's
era at zero a couple of saves two for
two and save opportunities
and a fly ball well struck center field
hernandez all the way back
it's over his head off the garage door
that'll bring in a run
and into second base he put a really
nice swing on that
he's got an rbi double breaking ball
and knocked down by arroyo collects guns
got him and that's the ball game
red sox have won it they knock off the
white sox today
7-4 that's your final score
red sox are down early they come from
behind again
marwyn gonzalez with a big home run
xander bow guys four hits today
so did [ __ ] hernandez red sox win it
to start this home standoff in style
seven
to four